and i guarantee you're going to get like  it's 200 000 views in like five minutes  let's do the staffer  wait who's gonna play the staffers  three chests oh he's got black okay do  you wanna be white no no no  okay i'll play  another favorite opening  how to do it  uh  that's right i don't think it'll work  but i'll still try it  i don't think it's gonna work though  you gotta treat every blunder as a  gambit  i don't think it'll work but i still  trying to take your knife  i see everything  i just don't want you to hurt me  he said i don't need to hurt you  you don't want me to hurt him  oh my god  he said thank you  very close to meeting there but um  not close enough  you see no work  oh  will be  oh kenny castle castle oh  yeah he's illegal that's unfortunate  he never didn't move  this guy's trying to crush me  he's trying his best to crush me man  what did i do to him  maybe  is  [Laughter]  this guy  he's the only guy that's bothering me  attacks him  all right